>> Hello everyone. Thank
you so much for coming.
We're very happy to have with
us Professor Miroslaw Staron,
from the University
of Gothenburg and
Chalmers in Gothenburg Sweden.
He's going to talk to us
today about his work on
autonomous AI-based measurement
systems in Ericsson,
Volvo, and a bunch
of other companies.
So, without much further ado.
>> All right, great.
Thanks. First of all,
thanks for having me.
I really appreciate coming
over to Microsoft Research.
So, who am I?
I'm as Seth said,
Professor in software
engineering.
I work mostly with
software measurement
in different areas.
I'm mostly working
with companies like
Ericsson and Volvo on that.
I'm also active in
standardization committees,
most recently in the
25,000 standards and
revision of those.
Those are basically the pictures
of things that we're
doing together with,
in this case, Ericsson and Volvo.
So, different kinds
of dashboards and
the measurement system
for decision support.
I brought the book that we
wrote together with
Wilhelm, my colleague.
You can browse it and I will
leave the copy with Nacci.
Yeah, so this is
basically our team.
It's both from
academia and industry,
and both me and
Wilhelm have been
working together for the
past 12,13 years now on
measurement systems.
We actually both,
we're located about
200 meters away
from each other to
different places.
So, we work a lot on
software measurement.
The context of
the whole collaboration
is the Software Center,
which is 11 companies
and five universities.
It's a collaboration
that is quite similar
to what you have at
Microsoft Research
but a bit different,
of course. It's more companies.
It's more universities,
and it's focused
on things like continuous
delivery on architecting,
on measurement and management,
and customer data and ecosystems,
working with
companies like Volvo,
Grundfos that make use of pumps.
Here a person who is
working with maps,
Bosch enzimas you
know, of course.
Not. So, why we
so excited about working
with a software center is
because gives us
the opportunity to work in
a very different way than
most academic research is done.
So, since this is
a formalized agreement,
we have the possibility to go to
one company, test the idea,
and after a while go
to another company,
test the idea and
improve that further,
and then move on to
more and more companies.
So this is how we basically do.
We take for instance the
code churning that Nacci
and some of your colleagues
have written a while back,
and we apply that at Ericsson,
and then a colleague
of mine Robert
has introduced me to heat-maps,
so we use heat-maps to visualize
churning in the
large product-based.
After a while, we took
that idea from Ericsson to SAP,
where they basically
said that well,
if you can visualize that,
maybe you can also predict
the coming changes,
or predict changes that should
be done but were not done.
So we did this that we
call the change waves,
and based on that when we
took it to Volvo trucks,
we could also predict
the impact of
change waves and that code
churning on the quality,
both of the quality of the code,
but also quality
of the final truck
that is driving around.
Then in the end we took
it to the Volvo cars.
It could actually bring
in both the defects and
requirements and code
into one dashboard.
It could predict
the wave of changes in
the requirements that would
spread to the source code,
that would spread
to the test cases,
that would spread to the quality.
So we could basically predict
the things about half a
year in advance. All right.
This kind of work
resulted in roughly
40,000 measurement systems that
we built at different companies,
and I will introduce you to what
a measurement system is later on.
But you could see this as
a gadget which
visualizes some sort
of measurements that
are being processed in
completely autonomous way
based on either big databases,
Excel, or BI behind it,
that has mechanisms for
example self-healing,
so that those 40,000
measurement systems if they
crash they could actually
repair themselves.
So this infrastructure
of 40,000 people is
maintained by roughly
2.5 percent per year,
which is very little, given
amount of work that they do.
So, thanks to
the self-healing that
we did was that instead
of spending hours a week,
they could spend hours a month on
maintaining those things and then
focus on new development.
We have worked a lot with
things about information quality.
So if you see a number
at the very top,
the defect backlog eight,
and you see the red dot,
that red dot is
actually showing if you can
trust the number or not.
So even if though we
can mathematically
get the number of defects,
there could be a lot
of properties for
instance the database may
not have been updated,
the defects are
outside of the limits
so even if you see eight
maybe you could expect 20,
so where are the other missing
defect and so on.
So we build a lot of
tech into the data,
that gives the stakeholder some
understanding if he or she could
trust that information on it.
Then we of course have
estimations of things,
for instance we
apply those change
waves analysis at Volvo.
So we could predict
if a change in
a standard of auto start,
how much that would cost to
implement in a new Volvo car,
and that analysis was usually
done during few months,
but thanks to Darko and his work,
he could do it in days.
They could press a button,
get a lot of information,
build a model, and
then they could just
evaluate if that model
was correct or not.
Then of course what we also
did is we could also apply
exactly the same
things to look at
the quality of requirements,
so we could pinpoint
requirements that did not
fulfill specific criteria
very early during the review.
So if you could review
a specification with
100,000 requirements,
instead of spending
weeks of reading all of
them and trying to
build a mental model,
that too would allow
you to focus on say
200 requirements that
really need your attention.
Maybe they are not consistent,
or they're not coherent,
or they need some extra
information or maybe they're
just wrong, planing usage.
So that is what we
did quite manually.
Now what we doing right
now is focusing a lot of
applying this machine learning
techniques and artificial
intelligence and measurement.
So, quite normally, when you have
a measurement program
in a company,
you take a lot of data and try to
build up some decision support,
you could see this as
a BI for instance, right?
It's an example of it,
but that requires a lot
of manual effort,
to find out what
the questions are,
what does the stakeholder want,
who is the stakeholder.
What their goals are and
what kind of measurements you do.
But if we apply,
for example, machine
learning in our AI,
those systems could
basically tell
you what is it that
you need to focus on.
So, in a case of a
company who has 40,000
measurement systems and
maybe hundreds of
thousands of measurements,
the AI could pick out
those measurements that are
off limits today and
focus your attention.
So, if you for instance focus
too much on quality and
then forget that
the important part
is to shift the features
in your product,
the measurement system will start
flagging that you're
lagging behind in
the feature development
or vice versa if you
just focus on new development
but don't test on it,
this AI will tell you that
now you should really
focus on testing because
your test progress
is slowing down,
and because of that they
suffer from quality and so on.
Could also gave you a lot
of simulations on that.
Where we came from is that
we started with working
on the manual predictions
long time ago,
we build a lot of prediction
models together with
Ericsson and then we found out
though those predictions are
very good but they are very
unreliable in many cases
because they are very
product-specific,
it's very difficult to
build a uniform model that
will predict number of defects
in any product in the world.
So, what we came up
with was that we could
automate certain
quality checks look
for example of if
the variables are metrics
or outside of limits,
and if they are outside of
limits we could tell you
that okay this is the
model that you can use.
You will get a number
but you shouldn't
trust the number because
the values are outside of
the range that are usually
predicted for that.
We focus on mostly
things like defect,
on faults or failures in
the product and then we
said that that's of
course a very good thing
but it's a very reactive thing.
So, we moved onto
cold stability
visualization where we used
cold churning and basically
characteristics of cold churning
to make prediction models.
Then we could build up things
like robust measurement progress
based on that so be able
to predict and warn
stakeholders a few months
before something happened that
you're going to
have problems with
this product or you're
going to have problems with
this module or you're
going to have problems
with that type of customers.
What we do today is we do
this AI based software
analytics when
we building a lot of intelligence
in the measurement called base.
So instead of
spending years and months
to analyze your data,
the AI gives you the answers
directly by itself so to say.
That brings me to how
do we do that, right?
So, if we take companies
like Ericsson or
Volvo or any other company
they have something they
call measurement program.
So, they have stakeholders,
they have information needs,
they measure things,
they measure product,
they measure processes,
productivity, quality
and aspects like that.
They tried to put them as
key performance indicators
to put on big monitors and
show how good are we today,
how many customers did we
get an how many
customers do we lose?
But those are very reactive,
they are set up by
people who have
domain knowledge and these people
based all of that on
their experience.
But as you know the world
is not built on experience,
the world is changing
all the time.
So, if you build things based on
your experience quite often
you can miss something.
What we do is we provide
more decision support to
exchange experience
with some new ideas.
So we build for example
algorithms based on decision
trees to come up with
new metrics that will
tell you that this is
an aspect that you don't
really cover based on
applied statistics
and things like that.
We do this quite often,
we have a repository of over
2,000 different metrics that
we constantly increase and
show different aspect
of what we do.
We have this self-healing
infrastructure that does it.
Imagine if you are processing
this amount of data you cannot
really manually monitor that
everything is right all the time.
So what we have is, we
have this systems that do
a lot of magic behind the scenes
looking at for instance
coloniality of data,
so the mathematical
properties of the data,
it looks at the processes
behind the data for instance,
has people been reporting
defects into the system,
have test cases being executed,
have code being checked
into the repositories,
all kinds of things?
Based on those aspects,
we could tell that for instance
something has happened in
the data that for example,
people have stopped checking
in the code into Git repository.
Meaning that one has to look into
that and decide if
that's something
that we should ignore or
is that something that
is not required. Yes.
>> What is self-healing
measurement?
What is that practicing mean?
>> So, in practice
that means that
sometimes if you
measure something,
say the closest example if
someone doesn't report a defect,
you may get a division by
zero somewhere, right?
In normal cases you could
visualize that idea was
an infinity or error or zero
but even if that's a number it
doesn't mean that it's
a correct number.
So, what the self-healing does
is that it looks
into why did we get
the missing defect and if that's
for example a missing connection
to the database,
it will try to pull
the database few more times
to try to get the data,
and maybe the database
needs to be restarted.
So, the self-healing mechanism
knows that it's a database,
it could be restarted
that way so it restarts
the database and that's a lot
of those kind of checks.
In most cases can fix the problem
with the missing data in
a much more meaningful way
than just having zero on that.
>> Who hosted by
a hardware operating
system applications or
just an application?
>> From your perspective that
will be mostly applications.
We don't do operating system
we don't go that deep.
All right let me move on then.
That is important with
this because this is
how a measurement system
could be visualized, right?
So, it's everything
from mobile phone apps,
gadgets in all times to websites,
to builds in continuous
integration or things that
based on sonar cube or
on Tableau dashboards
or Power BI or kinds of systems,
but that's just a visualization
at the final step, right.
What we do with the AI or
machine learning
is that we change
those visualizations
automatically.
So, in the old days one
could see that this was a,
let's take this picture, that was
a measurement system showing
bottlenecks in software
development program.
So, it was divided by phases
and what could look at
different activities
and the throughput
and cues and flow in the system,
but as you see that's
quite cluttered.
It's a many different diagrams
and don't really know
where to look for.
So, what we do today
instead of that is,
we take away
that picture and then
let the machine learning
look at decision trees and
regression models to
look at the dependencies
between different metrics
and then based on
the deviations from dependencies
we can basically say that for
instance now you have
a lot of queue in
the defect handling.
So, we visualize only this part
and so you should focus on that.
But if you have a little defects
but a lot of for example,
a lot of development and
a lot of integration,
we could visualize
something that's not on
this diagram that is a testing.
Saying that okay you
have developing a lot,
things are happening but
we don't see any defects.
Meaning that there must
be something wrong
with your testing so
look at your testing.
Are you testing enough? Are
you testing the right thing?
Are you may be
missing test cases?
Try to find out where are
the things that are not
really visualize or
not really there. Yes.
>> How do you go about training
the models that direct
people's attention?
>> What we do is that at
the beginning we train
that on historical
data but then we
have a model that over time looks
at when we should stop using
this particular trained model
and should we train the data.
So, we have an assemble
learner that over
time trains the model.
We basically fuse
on decision trees
and the random forests.
Over time when we
see that this model
is getting a bit off charge,
then we take away
that and we train
that on new model
continuously so to say.
>> So this was supervised
learning, right?
So, where does labels come from?
I mean at some point you
must have a label that
says this metric is
important at this moment.
>> So we have two things,
one it comes from
for example, information quality.
When we notice that
sometimes for instance
this data it's been off
the charts for example.
That we expect the defects
to be no more than say
10 per day but now we
just have 20 every week.
So, that lamp is
going to go red a bit
more and more and then someone
looks at that and say, "Okay,
should we retrain the
model or should we go to
the team and say look what's
wrong with your testing?"
So, that's one aspect.
The other aspect is that if
we get a new data
type for instance,
or new metric or we could
call it the new
feature for the model,
then we tried to retrain
the model based on
some simple algorithm and
then we use active learning
when for example
random forest give us
a high probability that
the algorithm doesn't know
where to classify that aspect.
Then the quality manager or
team leader has to press
the button "Is that
okay" or "Not okay. "
For the beginning we'll learn
using basic active learning.
So those two things,
information quality
and active learning.
>> Okay.
All right.
So, if it comes
to this information quality,
we'll look at two things.
So, the one I talked about is
the more internal quality,
when we look at the kind
of mathematical
properties of the data.
But we also look at
the external quality.
What does the stakeholder
think about the data?
So, this situation when
the metric is outside
of the limits,
and it's all based on
the ice of 5939 standard,
which is a standard showing how
the information in the
measurement system flows
basically from the attributes or
products until the information
needs of the stakeholder,
how that thing is build up,
and this whole monitoring
of information quality.
Now this is just a set of checks.
This whole monitoring is based
on checking properties of
every step of
the calculation to some.
That's a basic idea. Then if
something goes wrong like
this one for instance
that this check says that
the raw data was not
updated for example someone did
not report any defects yesterday,
then that will be more for
information system designer,
but for the stakeholder,
we'll just show red
without saying exactly what
is the problem.
Because the stakeholder think
about for instance
product manager,
a product manager
doesn't know exactly
which raw data is used and
how that is used and so on.
So he only gets the indication
for this moment,
you cannot really
trust that number,
but the metric design
he can go in.
He also gets that number
on his or her screen,
and he can go in and check
exactly which data was
not updated and what
to do about that.
Right? As I said,
it's based on the ice
of 5939 standard.
How we do machine learning in
that is that we add a lot of
things around that basic idea
of checks, right?
So if you have a lot of checks,
you could use
the checks as labels
for training of Machine
Learning to some extent,
and we basically do
this data collection.
So that was what you saw
simplified on
the right-hand side,
and on the left-hand side
is the other things
that are connected
to the organization.
For example how do we know that
a specific KPI is
really important for
that particular organization?
How do we know that Company X
has to focus on speed
and not on quality?
Wait, what does it say,
and then we'll look
at for example of
reference models from from
other industries or
other companies,
and try to compare them,
and see that company X is
much slower than company B,
and then company B
is in the same area,
but they could develop a lot
faster or integrate a lot faster,
and there comes the strength of
the collaboration we have
in the software Central
have different companies that
are quite open to each other.
So we could compare
and they could
learn from each other and
they could say, "look,
in our model we could integrate
within say half an hour,
and you can integrate
with and you
need a week to integrate
your software.
So, there is a possibility
for improvement on that."
Thanks to all this work
that we did based on
the culture learning,
and from you for instance,
we could teach the mothers to
find where the problems in
the code could actually
pop up based on the dependencies
between the cold churns
and for example testing.
So we'll have a regression
model that shows where are
the emission test cases or
which test cases we
could suggest to
execute based on a change in
the specific code module.
We'll also work on
the measurements under quality
from the perspective
of the impact
that they have on the company.
So, for example, we look at
the entire measurement program,
and an entire measurement
program could have
maybe up to 500 measurements
in them or indicators,
and we'll look and
try to identify
which of the indicators
are the leading ones.
Say, if you could only pick
10 percent of your indicators.
So, 50 indicators out of 500,
which would you pick?
Which 50 are
the most important ones?
You can look of course at
the mathematical properties
like colinearity
and codependency and try
to predict one another.
But what you could
lose is of course
the slight deviations
when for instance,
you have two indicators
and they are in 99 percent
of the weeks they
show the same status,
but this one percent of
the weeks when they actually
show different status and that's
o percent when it's
really important.
So we do a lot of work
with the stakeholders
when they provide us
with different weights of
different measurements
or measurement aspects
in the measurement program,
and based on those aspects
what we do is we could also build
a model saying that even if
mathematically two indicators
are correlated,
the important thing is to
show when they deviate
from one another,
that sort of one percent
when the correlation
is not perfect.
Again helps us a lot
if we're working with
multiple companies,
when we do a lot of work
with different sectors,
different types of stakeholders,
and different type of metrics,
and types of metrics for example,
this is our metric
portfolio summary.
The areas which we use,
for example we have
Cloud computing measurements.
Things like anything from
stability of the cloud
environment to
complexity of the code that is
behind the cloud execution,
scalability and so on.
But also project
metrics for example how
fast we deploy new features
on their customer site?
How fast we test?
How many reviews we do?
We look at the product,
we look at organizational
performance,
for instance how fast can
a feature go from an idea
to actually implement
that feature
and shipped to a customer?
Which is important in areas
like Telecom or automotive today.
We look at the customer site for
example a product delivery.
How do we know that a customer is
actually happy with
the product delivery?
I know that you work
with that a lot,
but in the areas
when for example
automotive is not as easy,
because you've shipped a car and
then it's out there driving.
So we don't really collect
the same kind of data since
the web system not
connected all the time.
So it's difficult to find
that kind of information.
But then we have
models and things
that help us out with this,
and if you're interested I
could show you more
about those metrics.
They come mostly from
either different papers,
or from the empirical
evidence companies
that we work with.
So, we'll look at what they
are measuring today and
what they know what works
and what doesn't work,
which could be quite a lot
of good evidence.
Instead of predicting,
previously we have
focused a lot on
predicting the values of metric
for example the defects.
What we wanted to predict
one the defects would come
and how many would come
in a specific product?
What we should do?
Where they would come?
So the location of the defects.
But right now, what we
tried to predict this
we tried to predict
the events rather than
things related to defect.
So, the numbers are
no longer important,
what is important is the trend,
are we going to be better in
a week or two or are
we going to be worse?
Should we prepare for something
or we should not on it?
Which is the entry point of
course to all of the
mathematics behind this,
but it's communicated in
much easier way so to say.
So, this is showing a gadget
it's roughly 10 years old.
Yeah, roughly to any source
but today we use
mobile phone apps and we use
emails instead of gadgets.
So the stakeholders don't have to
look at anything at all,
they will just get
an email when something
is out of range or they can
get an SMS or when
they're playing in
a mobile phone on that.
Which is a tremendous difference
because then we could
monitor more and
more data and then
for that we need this
machine learning
and the algorithm to monitor
and then we only support
the stakeholders when
something is really required
and really needed for that.
Of course we use a lot of
mathematics behind that.
So, very simple formulas
that are not based on,
so this an old formula showing
how many weeks are
needed to ship the
software to a customer.
So, in that case it's the work
we did with Ericsson.
So, if a customer to
Ericsson calls and say,
I want to have the
latest and greatest,
they need to know
how many weeks they need to
actually provide them with the
latest and greatest
software on their site.
Then they can also have
this on a mobile phone app,
how that works in this.
That was about eight years ago
when we started
working with that,
that was very good
because it showed very
succeed and very compact way of
showing the quality of
the product and
the plan deployment of that.
But that wasn't enough,
what was required was to have
a more prediction view of that.
So, what we did in one of
the studies is that we actually
used heatmaps to look at
the profile of a code.
So we would like to
know where do people do
changes in the code base
and how do they do that.
You can see two patterns.
In that example, this is
an agile software development,
where you see
the intensity of the color
basically says how much code was
changed per a particular week
a particular module.
As you see in an agile
development you have changes
all over the place on that,
but this is an example of
a product which is more
a platform versus
application-based,
and you see that quite a lot that
there is a group of people
working with the platform,
and they do a lot of work all
the time as in those cases.
Then you see fragments of
the code which are basically
different applications,
and there you see
a completely different patterns,
you see not read all over
the place but you see
blobs when they focus on
a specific feature that is
or specific application
in that area,
and then they move
on to another one,
and so on and so on.
This way of visualizing
this was actually a big hit
showing that you could predict
things for example
missing updates.
So, if we look at
the big middle of that heatmap,
one can of course start
asking the question,
why don't we do
anything in that area?
What's the area for?
If historically you build
a model saying that there are
some changes in this area,
and as you see that
those dots sometimes have
this property that one
happens before the other.
So you could actually
try to build a model.
As I said the code change wave,
saying that if always this module
is changed the week
before that module,
I mean, why don't we
have that change in
some week so you could
identify missing changes
for example, right?
They don't have to be
missing changes but it's
definitely an input for someone
to look at that code
and say, "Look,
if you have usually
make change to module B
after you make a
change in module A,
why haven't you
done at this time?"
That kind of way of
visualizing code also
helps the teams to
prioritize test cases.
So they could look at
this model and say, "So,
now in this particular week we
work very much in
those two modules,
have we tested those modules
at the same speed
or have we tested
another part of code?
How do we know that the code
quality is so good on that?"
So the input to the decision.
At the beginning we had
this as a manual input,
right now we build in more of
a prediction models that
could tell that for instance,
if we have exactly the same
heatmap but on a test cases,
we could show that in
the same week we have
usually made a
change in module A,
and then usually test case
X have reacted on that sort
of found the defect.
We could prioritize test cases
based on culture and
try to provide this
as a feedback to
the test leader saying, "Look,
this is how your test strategy
should be designed
in the next few weeks
if your changes are
going to be like that."
That kind of approach
let us also to
look in at the standards
for the automotive.
So, Draper who is working
for Volvo has been looking
at the changes in
the AUTOSAR standard,
which is a huge standard kind
of like an operating
system for a car.
You could see this that way.
What he could do with
his change waves and with
his optimization of the code,
he could predict the impact of
a particular change
in the standard on
the cost of a
development of a car.
So, that standard could
say that for instance,
we add one attribute
to some construct or
some function in this,
say operating system,
and he could predict
how much that will
cost the company in terms
of change management,
in terms of new development,
is the new version of
the operating system or
standard going to be backward
compatible with the
software we have,
and so on and so on.
But he could also do is
that he could look at
the Pareto front and could
identify the best
combination of features.
So, if you develop
the car and say,
I want to have
this particular feature,
you could find that in
this and say, okay,
if I want to have this feature,
all of these features I
get for free because
I still need to
develop that because of
that particular feature, right?
So, that gives you a discovery of
new business possibilities when
you develop those kind
of big systems, right?
Then we talk about 100 to
200 different computers and
tens of thousands of
different functions in the car.
So it gets pretty
complex with that.
Thanks to this analysis
of the changes,
he could basically quickly
predict and provide
more information
to people on that.
Based on that model
he could also say
that if we want to implement,
say this feature and what's
the cost to implement
the next one
and what is this difference,
so what do we get if we move
on to the next level so to say,
and identified also the sort
of optimum when the cost
is basically much more than
the benefit that you get
from those features that you
shipped to the customers,
which is pretty interesting
for car manufacturers.
But on the other hand,
he looked at
the very similar thing
but he looked
at that from the perspective
of requirements, right?
So, if you have 100 to 1,000
requirements specification,
you would like to
quickly find out
the requirements that
are connected that are
incoherent that are really badly
written to focus
all your effort on that.
So, he developed that model
based on simple measurements
of requirements,
kind of like a very basic
natural language processing,
but without any semantics,
and he could build that part of
the toolchain at the company.
So, right now when
this company is working
with requirements,
when they specify
the requirement,
they get to directly
very quick feedback
saying how good or how
bad that requirement is,
and they also could get
an impact of why this is
a good or a bad
requirement very quickly.
I could give you an example
of that is for instance,
if you are implementing
something and then
you say that in
your new track you should
implement standard 25026,
which is a very nice requirement
if you write it,
but then you open up the standard
25026 that's like 2,000 pages.
So, what do you mean by
implement the standard?
In fact, which page?
So, this model would catch
the situation and say,
look, in this requirement,
there's something
fishy, looks very
nice but it's very
inspecific, right?
You need to be very clear
about which page or
which area of the standard
you should implement
this so to say.
Which saves the company's
hundreds of engineer in
hours in backtracking
requirements that
should be specified to be
better at the beginning
of the development cycles.
Something that
my colleague Miriam is
working on mostly is
now looking at that.
If you look at
the professional companies
that develop software like you,
you have coding guidelines what
people can do and
cannot do in the code,
and you can use of
course style checkers
to check what many
of those but many of
the guidelines cannot
really be done using
style checkers because writing
the rule for that would
be very difficult,
it's not straightforward
to do that.
So, what my colleague is doing
is he's building a
machine learning
model to train how to
recognize violations
in the design by providing
examples of a code.
So when you do
a review and get it,
you look at the code that's
been reviewed and say,
this is a good code,
that is a bad code,
and then this machine
learning algorithm
learns which is
a good and bad code,
so the next time you
get the supporting Garrett
saying, "Look,
this is a probably rule violation
in that code or that
code looks good to me."
So, over time that
review speed gets
very much shorten because
you don't have to read
the codes anymore,
the machine learning
algorithm gives you
a good example of what is
a violation or not on it.
Of course since this
is all based on
probabilities you never get
100 percent correctness, right?
So, if we will look at how
far we can go for
very big code bases,
we need to train an algorithm,
we say roughly 300 lines
of code and then we get
roughly 70 percent accuracy
in recognizing,
which for a company
that does review
on a daily basis there's a lot
of speedup because they
get two out of three lines
that they identified,
this is actually
true positive and
one line is false positive,
but that's okay
because they still can
take the stand on their own.
The novelty of this is
that what we do is,
we don't use any static models,
is we would teach
the machine learning
based on the codes.
So we show the
algorithm the code,
and we tag the lines which
are good and which are bad,
and then it builds
a model by itself.
Looking at things like,
which words are used,
what kind of patterns
are used in the code,
how long the lines are,
how many brackets when using
a single line of code
and things like that.
Yeah.
And again thanks to
the collaboration with
different companies in
the software center,
we could test
exactly the same rules at
different companies and look at
how they think about
coding violations.
Because I know, if you
do code reviews, but,
if you've done code review,
you know the rules look
very simple on paper.
But, then, if you look
at the code and have to
decide if the rule is violated or
not it's not always that
straightforward because
sometimes there is
still quite a lot of
interpretation how the
rules should be done.
Thanks to using machine
learning and decision trees,
one could actually
backtrack how things are
working and when things
are going bad so to say.
You don't have any questions
or you've already
done that right?.
Okay. So, I'm preaching
to the choir.
What we did also is, we started
the patterns of how measurement
information is actually
spread across the companies.
So, instead of having
big monitors at landscapes
that everyone looks at and no one
really gets a lot of
information from,
we started who is communicating
with whom in a
company and then we
could direct the information
directly to the people,
who are interested on that.
So looking at- [inaudible].
>> Could be through
the communications,
could be through the dashboards
that automatically
adapt where people
sit, different things, right?.
Yeah. And then we
also look at things when
people build dashboards.
So, think about, for example,
if they have to
decide between using
the PowerBI or
a gadget or an email.
How do they decide today?
Well, today, they
basically look at what
the purpose of that is and
find out what they want to do.
But, we have this model
that helps them to
choose quite quickly.
So, it's like you can see
like a slider when you
configure buying a new car or
buying a new mobile phone.
We do exactly the same thing
for a dashboard.
So, you do play around with
different parameters and
then by the end of the day,
you get an idea about
what kind of dashboard you are
building and it could
also help you in
some cases to choose what kind of
measurements one could use.
Based on selling those patterns,
we also found out that
instead of working with
measurements in
terms of dashboards,
quite many people
actually want to work
with measurements in
terms of a cloud.
So, they would like to have
their own private
measurement system put
in our own cloud environment,
which is extremely simple,
but still quite powerful and then
spread the information
to other colleagues
in a very simple way that will be
automatically updated and
automatically spread out.
We found out that it could
reduce up to 50% of the cost
of measurement for the company
and then increase, of course,
empowerment of the teams,
who want to have their own
measurements instead of having
a central body [inaudible].
That is based, of course,
on very simple technology.
So, it's not like Azure cloud.
It's much, much simpler.
It's maybe 1,000 lines
of code of the cloud environment
that we use. Sorry?
>> It's not a lot.
>> No. I think that is not a lot.
That says extremely
simple crowd, right?
But, it's extremely powerful
for that particular
purpose, right?
Because what it basically does,
it spreads around
different messages to
different agents and then
tells them to update
measurement systems, right?
So, it's extremely simple,
but extremely powerful and
the things that we
have discovered,
thanks to that kind
of environment,
was that it's a much more
robust to changes
in the environment.
So, for example, if
one computer goes down,
it's extremely easy to just
recover the measurements.
In the previous architecture,
which we had was much
more server-based,
so, we had to have backups
and things like that.
Now, all of that is, of course,
automatically because you
have it in the cloud, so,
you have a lot of the same kind
of computers that
are using exactly the same kind
of measurements,
so, you can easily get it back.
So, to wrap up,
yeah, that's what we do
together with my colleagues.
This autonomous
measurement systems
that change themselves.
That change the way the
companies work with measurement
instead of having dedicated
large teams to
maintain measurements,
we could achieve that with
very, very small teams.
I'm not fan of size of the team,
but the size of
the team, of course,
determines the cost
of the measurement
program and in every company,
the measurement program
is not really something
that you sell, right?
I mean, Ericsson doesn't
sell measurement system.
They sell Telecom notes.
[inaudible] doesn't sell measurement
system, they sell cars, right?
So, they would like to have
this same information with
as little cost as possible and
that's exactly what we're doing.
So, maximizing the benefit
with the minimum cost on it.
So, with that, thanks a lot.
If you have any questions
or any feedback,
I'll be super happy to hear that.
>> Thanks.
>> companies A and B.
You learn something from
Company A and you want
to use it on company B.
Is company A okay with you taking
learnings and applying
it to company B?
>> Most often yes and in
some percentage that's
never a problem.
>> So, there are, I mean,
part of the goal is
also to build
a transferable model?
>> Yes.
>> [inaudible] improve
their way of measuring and
somehow now the liability of
the production has gone up,
why wouldn't they want
to let this information
go and be useful for
the competitors?
Because they can make better
[inaudible] level cars,
that's their IP.
>> In the software center,
the whole thing is built on
the idea that there are
no competitors inside and
if you want to join
a software center,
all the companies have
the right to veto.
So, for example, if
you have a Volvo in
software center and BMW would
come over and say I want
to be part of that,
Volvo could easily say sorry.
Their competitors will veto
that. So they cannot join.
So, all the companies that are in
that collaboration are not
competitors. Meaning that-.
>> They work in
different domains.
>> So, from this example,
A and B are not competitors.
That is why they're
linked to same data?
>> Exactly. And, of course,
they don't share all of
the data completely open,
for example, right?
Ericsson doesn't
give source code to
Volvo and vice versa, right?
They could meet on a workshop
and show each other their code,
but they're not giving
that to them, right?
>> How often do you see
that models need tweaking.
Suppose, you build like
estimated defects model
in Volvo and you want
to apply in Ericsson.
Does it apply off
the box or is there
a fair amount of
manual tuning that goes on
[inaudible] methodology the same
or it is the model
itself just the same.
[inaudible] takes the same
coefficient [inaudible].
>> Now. It's mostly the
methodology that is the same.
All of the companies have,
even though they have,
maybe in some cases,
very similar set of tools,
they do things differently.
So, for example,
just the sheer number
of test cases that they
have could be so different
that the coefficient
would not make sense.
So, based on that, but
the methodology is the same.
And, of course, if you look at
how much effort is spent
on coming up to the model,
of course, coming up with
a methodology, for instance,
trying out different models
is what it takes time, right?
And then if you know
exactly what kind of
steps you can do,
it's much easier to replicate.
It takes maybe 10 percent of the
time of the original time.
>> So, every model
that is getting
reclaimed every time
you want to transfer
technology to a new
company, for example,
Writing better code,
the example you gave earlier,
I can imagine writing code for
telecommunication company
can be different
from writing code for
an automobile company.
>> Yeah.
>> So then, you have to manually
or ask the company to be fully
engaged again in the beginning
and retrain the models.
>> Yeah, that's true.
So, if you look at
this particular example of that,
what we were so happy
about is that it
takes only five trials,
so to say, so five
learning cycles to
get to a pretty decent
accuracy of the model.
Because every company, and
even within the same company,
different products have
different coding guidelines.
Some products are written in C,
some products are written in C++,
they have completely
different rules.
So, what we are focusing
on is to minimize this.
So ideally, we would
have just one run.
Show me the code and then
I teach the model then I run it,
but that's maybe a topic,
we cannot do that.
So, up to five, we need
to have at least today,
five routes of doing that.
The whole idea that we're
working on is, as I mentioned,
to have a sample learning
so that over time,
the rules will change and
then the model will
also change, so to say.
So, right now, we're trying
to find out the break point
when the model should actually
automatically adjust,
when is the model not
good enough anymore,
so that the model
could think about
it or come up with
that idea by itself.
But the training is really
important because the rules
are extremely different,
and they call, how they apply
and how they're understood,
they also very different.
>> The metrics
should be different.
>> No, the metrics inside here,
they're identical for
all the companies.
The set of features that
we use in the model,
they're exactly the same.
But how you write
the code, for example,
how do you use capital letters
or underscores will differ
from company to company,
from product to product,
and the data types
that use also differ.
So, instead of coding
that heart into
the machine learning,
we've tried to extract that,
so we use things
like bag of words
to understand which language
you basically use.
What is a variable?
What is the type?
What is the name?
What is a function?
If you just analyze
the code, of course,
the keywords will
pop up much more
frequently than any other words,
because keywords are the same,
but names of variables change,
so we learn using
those techniques.
>> You mean you dynamically
identify the language?
>> Yes.
>> Then apply the rules
for specific [inaudible].
>> Exactly.
>> In some cases, you can even,
depends of course on
the rules, but in some cases,
you use rules that you
trained on Java code on
the C++ code because they
are not that much
different in some cases.
>> These checks for code,
they are only trying
to find, let's say,
unintended bad code
or bad mistakes,
somebody changed the variable.
How will you go about
trying to detect,
let's say, malicious
fault in the code?
Let's say in the case of
a model, like in diesel cars,
they will now updating
the variables so that it
reports low emission
that actually does,
and this was maliciously put in.
So, the software was
looking for code,
quality isn't going
to catch that.
How will you catch
that kind of problem?
>> That I don't really know,
because we didn't work with that.
But I guess if you have
examples of a code that
does this thing that could
be applicable as well.
But we have not done with those.
>> Because if you have seen that
only the values for
these variables
always are in the range of 0-50,
and suddenly there's
a new update to
the code and it makes
its value 5,000,
will your system
flag that right now?
>> Right now, no.
If that's not the part
of the coding guideline,
then it will never flag that.
>> I see. Okay.
>> How many people
worked on this project?
>> On this project, it's
only two people working.
>> I mean the whole
measurement system?
>> We are, I think, 15,
20 people in the team,
both in academia and industry.
In academia, we focused
mostly on the development of
the meat of that,
so the algorithms and our
colleagues from industry,
they usually work
on applying that
so they will take that
and apply that and
see if that works for
them or not to give us
feedback and help us
train the models.
>> You requiring
the [inaudible] set, the models,
and then you just release it and
the development team can
collect all the data?
>> Yes.
>> So, in the previous
part of the talk,
you talked about some vastness
of the measurements,
trying to figure out
which measurement should be
more indicative or flagged.
What models do you use for that?
Because I can't
imagine those being
thousands of measurements
that might be correlated,
not correlated, what kind
of models do you use
to figure out these connections
between them as you
would they are in?
>> We use extremely
simple models.
So, we start with a PCA,
and look which variables
are colinearly correlated,
and then we provide
that feedback to
the stakeholder saying,
"Look, those variables,
they're always in the same
component," for example,
and then they would say,
"Yeah, but this metric,
for example, should only
be identified when it's
not correlated with
something else," so
we don't want to see
both of them in the
measurement system.
We want to see, for example,
the delta or deviation
between one or the other,
or only the weeks when
they deviate somehow.
But the statistical methods
are not that complicated to use.
>> Do you do
a separate analysis of
which metrics or measurement,
which measurements
affect which metrics?
For example, if I
see some measurements that are
dependent for these metrics,
they might not be dependent
on another different metric,
do you join in that system?
>> Not in that way, no.
Well, we tried that but it
didn't really work out,
because the models were
basically too complex.
So, we used the graph theory
to draw a graph of which metrics
are dependent on what,
but the models were
too complex and we
couldn't really get
any meaningful results.
So, that's why we
use much simpler PCA
and just statistics and then
flag things. [inaudible]
>> Because your model
is only as good
as your interpretation of it,
so if you cannot interpret
those [inaudible] graphs,
then you have to rely
on the statistics.
>> Exactly. That's why we,
for example, also in this,
don't really go to deep learning
or neural networks,
but we prefer models
like decision trees or,
basically, decision
trees which can provide
their own interpretation
why they classify
a specific line as
a deviation and why not,
so that we could use this
either as a input to training,
if it's a false positive,
or as understanding that "Okay,
we are missing
a feature in our model
so we need to add
something so that
this flag does not get
recognized as a false positive."
With neural network,
that's really difficult.
The thing is also that for
neural networks and on
a more complex model,
you need to have
really huge datasets.
You cannot really expect
an architect to sit
down and talk 7 million
lines of code,
which lines had
violations or not.
So, 300 and 600 lines of code is
probably max what you can ask
someone to help you with tagging.
So, we need to have a model
that you can trace back
and to understand that if you,
for example, the model
gives you a false positive,
why is this a false positive.
How should I provide
a counter example
to teach the model
in a better way?
You cannot do that
with a black box,
with models that are black box.
Hope that helps.
>> If there are
no other questions,
let's thank Professor
Miroslaw Staron.
>> Okay. Thank you
very much.Thanks.